Good morning Hank it's Tuesday!
So many Nerdfighters made amazing book towers
that I figured I should give it a try myself
so let's head up to the library.
By the way Hank, I have a library.
While I have this voice-over opportunity,
I want to recommend three recent reads.
First Ta-Nehisi Coates's amazing book Between
the World and Me which I cannot stop thinking
about.
Second, The Bail Trap link in the dooblydoo
an article in The New York Times that explores
one of the reasons people in poverty are disproportionately
imprisoned in the United States.
And third, another article in The New York
Times about a fourteen year old boy locked
in solitary confinement which I found chilling
and deeply upsetting.
Also since those are all tough reads, I recommend
a GIF of a puppy jumping for the first time,
link in the dooblydoo.
AAAHHH Dangit!!
Well there you have it Hank, couldn't build
a house of cards in 2007 and can't build a
house of books in 2015, some things never
change.
Okay, insert artful transition here, Hank
I took the Nerdfighter Census survey yesterday,
great survey as always but I felt like some
of the questions weren't inclusive of me,
like the question "Do you follow John on Twitter?"
I just didn't know how to answer that because
technically I don't, but I also kinda feel
like I do.
I mean, I see most of John's tweets.
Also, you asked me whether I watch videos
at school, which I don't, because that would
be creepy, but not whether I watch videos
at work.
Which I do because technically, like, watching
Akilah Hughes get drunk and review books is
my job, well that and semi-professional FIFA
playing.
Speaking of which Hank, behold the wonder
of the John Green Stand at AFC Wimbledon's
stadium.
Okay Hank but there was one question I did
not appreciate at all, question twenty five,
the one where you pit my beautiful unwavering
puff against your fancy new hair style by
asking "Who has better hair, Hank or John?".
Now Hank we use the Nerdfighter Census every
year to figure out what topics we should cover
on Crash Course and what sort of videos we
should make on Vlogbrothers and it helps us
to understand the interests and passions of
Nerdfighteria
and I'm so grateful to everyone who fills
it out but I don't want to submit my hair
to a popular vote.
In fact Hank, just seeing that question made
me go out and and get this haircut, and I'm
worried that soon, in an attempt to impress
Nerdfighteria and win their pileous support,
we'll have an ever escalating arms race, like
the US and the Soviets did in the 1980s, only
with hair instead of nuclear weapons.
Until eventually one of us goes bankrupt and
our empire collapses.
Is that what you want Hank?
And yes, I did just use the word pileous,
meaning of or relating to hair.
This whole hair thing is making me so anxious
that my vocabulary is coming out.
Hank, one of the weirdest and most beautiful
things about Nerdfighteria is that in eight
years, they've never allowed us to have, like,
a proper sibling rivalry.
It's never been about Team Hank or Team John,
it's always been about Team Hank And John.
Or as I prefer to think of it, Team John And
Hank.
But you put that question in the survey Hank,
so I guess you want a contest, and you're
gonna get one.
Here's the thing about John's hair, Hank.
You may not always agree with it, but you
have to respect it's honesty.
John's hair, the Puff, has remained fundamentally
unchanged over the last eight years, it grows
and shrinks with my anxiety levels but at
it's core, the Puff is the Puff.
This is hair without product or artifice or
gimmicks, I'm not sure you can say that about
Hank's hair, but I'm not going to run a negative
campaign.
You're never going to hear me say "Hank, what's
it like having a haircut that Tyler Oakley
discarded in 2011?"
And I would never point out that Hank has
the haircut of a young Republican and the
face of a de-mustachioed Leon Trotsky.
Nope, you'll never hear that from me because
my hair is keeping it positive.
Let me just submit that a vote for John's
hair is a vote for stability, and brotherhood,
and unity.
So friends, please fill out the 2015 Nerdfighter
Census, and when you do, consider the Puff.
Also if you have a job please fill out the
Nerdfighter Census because right now I can't
tell if it's selection bias or if the unemployment
rate in Nerdfighteria is actually 85 percent,
which would be quite worrisome, it would put
us at the very bottom of like, uh, all countries.
Hank, you're a good brother and you have good
hair.
It's just not this good.
I'll see you on Friday.